A long time ago,
maybe three decades or so,
kids are the ones who taught us to care
about the environment.
We as the adults were terribly wasteful.
We were buying hardwoods.
We weren't recycling.
Uh,
we were just dumping things in the
rivers.
We really didn't have an environmental
protection agency that was worth
anything.
I'm not sure if we have one that's worth
much today,
but we have one and so we learned and we
adjusted and so it is with really young
people today who were teaching us that
animals deserve protection.
They aren't things.
They are fellows with us on the earth
and that we need to adjust our thinking
in the same way we did with
environmentalists,
but it happens that it is all tied
together because the whole ecology of
the earth depends on so many different
species that intermix with their roles
and keeping the earth and the air and
the water's clean and healthful.
You know,
you can go to some remote parts of
Alaska.
There are very few of them left today,
but you can and you can say,
oh look,
it's uninhabited,
but it's pristine.
It's not uninhabited.
It's inhabited by billions upon billions
of creatures from the tiniest insect to
the wolf,
to the Eagle,
to the beaver.
All these animals have lived there,
but they've never heard their
environment at all.
We come in with all bulldozers and our
heavy equipment and our oil pipelines
and everything else.
We are leaking oil.
Let's see from our ships,
we have causing the animals of the
oceans to die because of the noises of
drilling and what have you.
We have to learn that this isn't all
about us.
We are just ruining our own nest,
so it is a big environmental movement
and so the alignment between animal
rights and the environment should be
absolute and that doesn't even count the
what we're doing with our diet because
our diet is the most polluting water
intensive resource consuming an
occupation that we have on earth.
We are just deforesting take cutting
down the trees so we can make cheap
grazing land.
We are pulling the water out of the
earth so that we can grow crops and
instead of eating the crops ourselves,
we need 10 to 16 times as many crops to
feed to the animals who we ultimately
take more water to slaughter,
to transport,
and so on.
It is just a disaster.
Animal based agriculture has got to go
and sooner or later it will because the
water supply,
we'll,
we'll run out.
We don't think for a moment that animals
have more rights than human beings.
What we think is that human beings are
clever enough and moral enough to have
responsibility to the others on the face
of the earth.
So animals are never going to do the
things we do.
I don't know any aunts who put down
poison for human beings.
I don't know any squirrels who've
declared war in Iraq.
You know,
we uh,
the great,
uh,
override as of everything we,
we're the great decision makers about
everything.
And we have very,
very destructive for the animals take
for their need.
And we take for our greed.
You know,
you could reconstruct flocks of birds
and herds of cattle from just the
leftovers that are on the trees outside
in the car door of my hotel today,
that there's animals didn't die for any
good purpose and they didn't die.
Well,
they die because we fancied something
and we ordered more than we could ever
eat.
I think we need to be responsible and
Peter has a great hope that human beings
can be more like grownups and like big
fat,
greedy children and that we can look out
for the basic needs of animals,
which is leave me in peace.
Don't hurt me when you don't have to
choose something that's kind instead of
something that's cruel live by the
golden rule of do unto others and
include the animals too.
To me,
because there are billions upon
billions.
Something like $16 billion animals
killed for food every year in this
country alone.
That's an awful lot of individuals and
maybe a $100,
million animals killed in awful ways and
experiments every year and others use in
the circus and dissection in the
clothing industry and so on.
When I opened the paper and I see an
absence of coverage for all these
individuals,
then I feel that we have yet to wake up
to a core part of what's going on in the
world.
If we are to self obsessed and we have
to narrow in our consideration of who is
us now.
I saw a bumper sticker that says I am
you only different,
and I couldn't see who was driving the
car turned and afterwards I thought,
well actually it doesn't matter who is
driving,
whether it was a man or a woman,
White,
black,
Chinese doesn't matter.
And that was the message is that I am
you only different and all those
billions of individuals and it took us a
long time to even know that the people
we institutionalized where individuals
that people of other races were
individuals that slaves,
Africans who were brought to this
country.
We didn't think of them as individuals.
They weren't in the paper other than if
one ran away and we had to go and
retrieve all possession.
So the absence of the coverage about all
the other animals who have interests is
the biggest thing that hits me when I
watched the news or
on the paper.